the idea that you want for bread so it's
sort of this prosperity doctrine that's
only attached to and to cuss ilysm and
in terms of the broader context that
we're talking about its ability to
promote human flourishing you know
people who participate but give are
wanting for bread and but then will give
whatever little they have to these
megachurches to the building of certain
if you could just comment on that yes
yes yes well I mean you invest in sacred
bonds of Ike these bonds unlike some
other bonds their social bonds by the
way you're interesting you're investing
in social bonds and and they're divinely
guaranteed now there's nothing like I
mean that the federal bank is nothing
compared with the divine guarantee so
forgiving being slightly facetious but I
mean basically that if there is this
guarantee and the guarantee to some
extent weren't works because it is
asserted there is there is there is a
sense in which when the thing is
believed it becomes true one have to be
a bit careful with this this argument
but but that if you are given the sense
that Providence is on your side once you
once you feel that then you feel
empowered you feel empowered as a group
and you feel empowered them in the
individual and you're giving to the
organization and even if you're giving
attempt you have the sense that this
organization on the whole assists your
flourishing journalists when I give my
spiel of this sort tend to be a highly
skeptical set of people and they
regarded as a form of of sacred
exploitation my view is that actually
people have some good sense of what what
does them good and this relationship
between God and what does you good in
right you know
a wide range of senses of the word good
i think is achieved within these
megachurches they're not my they're not
my world I I don't need to join one
myself but I have in the article in the
times literary supplement I mentioned
that they have the business schools
attached so that you learn how to
conduct a business but they also have
large-scale community banks which
somebody was telling me one of one of
the students was telling me over over
lunch that these are very lacking in in
Africa so if you've got the hagi I
community bank just imagine at the hagi
I community bank that is run by your
particular religion then you are buying
into something that really has got a lot
going for it